FRONT OF BLOCKED.
IT WAS THAT TIME GETTING IN
OFF THE FACE-OFF.
THE SHOT BLOCK.
ANOTHER SASA.
>> Kenny: ALEX
YOU MENTIONED THE 25 FLORIDA  S.
VERHAEGHE TO THE PUCK.
MONTOUR.
DEFENDND FOR THE PANTHERS.
>> Eddie: THEY'RE HAVING WORDS.
CALL.
BACK ACROSS BY JAN RUTTA.
RUTTA AND  YOU CAN COMES OUT TO.
AND THEN THE SHOT BYE OF
ANDRE.
HE SEEMS IT. FOR A CHANGE.
THE LONG PASS FOY
THE PANTHERS.
JAN THERE'S
SHOT FROM BEA
PLUS CHANCE OFF TH FOLLOW US.
>> THE LIGHTNINGS A HAND TOSS.
DEFINITELY.
>> Kenny: PALAT FOR THE AS THE
LIGHTNING.
GETS THE PUCK OUT, SHOOTS IN.
FACES S F THERE.
GREAT STICK BY M
HARD WORK BY
THE STICK BELOW THE HEIGHT OF
THE CROSS BAR.
IT LOOKS LIKE A GOOD GOAL FROM
MY VANTAGENG THAT OPPORTUNITY.TT
.
STAMKOS.
MAKES THE SHOTOUTSTANDING
EFFORT TO CHIP I AHEAD.
FOR VERHAEGHE.
INTO THE
BROKEN UP BY CIRELLIFORSLING.
I MEAN, YOU TALK ABOUT A STOP
AND A HALF THERE